[موسيقى]
يشكل اليوم مرحله مرحله
تعطي دفعه جديده للعلاقات الكوريه
السعوديه 26
اتفاق ما بين الشركات السعوديه والكوريه
بقيمه تجاوز ال 29 مليار دولار
[موسيقى]
تاتي هذه الزياره لبلادكم دائما مع مرور
60 عاما على انشاء العلاقات بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وجمهوريه كوريا مما يؤكد
رغبه بلدينا في الاستمرار في ترسيخ اسس
هذه العلاقه التاريخيه والعمل على استكمال
الجهود الراميه الى تعزيز التعاون في جميع
المجالات
[موسيقى]
لتكثيف العمل المشترك لمواجهه كل ما يهدد
الامن والسلم الدوليين وياثر على امن
الطاقه وسلامه سلاسل الابداع
[موسيقى]
طبعا وصل بالامس ولي العهد السعوديه وكان
هناك استقبال رسمي له في المطار كلام
متواجد رئيس الوزراء الكوري اجر معه
مباحثات واليوم ايضا تم اللقاء مع الرئيس
الكوريه واكد الجانبان على اهميه هذه
العلاقه ان تكون متينه وخاصه على مختلف
السعود ان كان سعيد اقتصادي او صعيد
الدفاعي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]